para los militares en el poder desde
hace nueve años el revés es inmenso la
elección del pueblo tailandés es Clara
son los dos partidos de la oposición que
salieron Víctor yusos de los comicios de
este domingo dos formaciones
prodemocracia que supieron aprovechar el
movimiento de protesta anti ejército de
2020 ambas dicen estar listas para
negociar una coalición de gobierno y
cambiar el curso de la historia política
Tailandia
tenemos suficientes diputados para
aprobar todas las reformas legislativas
que queremos el gobierno será una
coalición simple en el sentido de que
como prometimos no incluirá los partidos
apoyados por el ejército y se basará en
un protocolo de entendimiento como en
las democracias occidentales habrá
transparencia
en el lado militar que ha gobernado
Tailandia desde un golpe en 2014 se
admite La derrota cumpliré con mi deber
lo que pueda sea lo que sea trabajaré
toda mi vida por la nación la religión
el rey Esa es la ética de nuestro
partido Espero que el país tenga paz y
prosperidad
establecido por el ejército el sistema
electoral nacional es complejo de los
500 escaneos del parlamento la oposición
debe tener al menos el tres cuarto para
compensar El poder del senado cuyos 250
miembros fueron todos nombrados por la
junta el ejército por lo tanto mantenga
una gran influencia política